are you tired of the same old tavern
brawls hearthstone is going to see some
big changes this spring blizzard has
announced new standard and wild modes
for the virtual card game standard mode
is meant for casual friendly games but
you can also play ranked you can use
cards from the Blackrock Mountain Grand
Tournament and League of explorers
expansions but not every card in the
game is available the goal is to keep
each match dynamic and balanced while
making it easier for new players to
learn the ropes wild mode is a different
story it's basically the hearthstone
you're playing now anything can happen
because any card is usable you can keep
earning gold completing quests and
ranking up as much as you want and if
you've already unlocked all nine heroes
you'll get nine extra deck slots which
brings the total to 18 overhauling a
game can be dangerous but it looks like
blizzard found the best of both worlds
with this one there's a full faq on
battlenet if you have any concerns in
the meantime keep playing hearthstone
and keep visiting GameSpot for a full
deck of news and reviews